um talk to me about who is on the label
oh I'm your who's
umbrella Seattle he's been here before
what's up uh Rick Carter Bree Carter
stop shot hey is Brie Cartier
let's say you're a lady or my mother of
my children your baby mama okay yeah
okay uh mother of my children you're
you're a mother of your children yes yes
all right okay oh
she's on she's on there
um she was on the gz record too right
correct
uh Mike Wayne
okay copy poppy uh splack
um I've got another artist named Melody
Melody baby
uh he's Egyptian and he's just tight
he's got a dope as a voice
um
we got producers that's just under the
umbrella right you know
um
Larry Jay hmm
wow my boy man we got him
89 [ __ ] with us
um
my boy oh Freddy Ruger
and we just you know
we're just flying is there anything you
learned because you would obviously
been under the 10 something I want to
shout out G4 too G4 yeah young cat too
try G4 yeah you [ __ ] I'm [ __ ] you
know so that's just family I'm just
speaking on people that's just a lot of
times I speak on just family and knowing
that I you know I want to you know share
my platform why not you feel me what you
should do yeah yeah I'm not that type of
person where you just like if you ain't
signing me I'm not [ __ ] with you no
more right type [ __ ] I was gonna say
what did you learn from
um the 10 summer situation that you're
applying to amio because mustard
obviously
is a [ __ ] boss you know what I'm
saying um you guys put out some timeless
music together for sure was there
anything you learned from that uh
experience that you're applying to your
own imprint now
if so
I learned a lot from myself I learned
you know
first hand on how to deal with you know
situations at hand you feel me even
being involved with you know I'm saying
who you're involved with it's just like
you know always you know I mean do you
you know I mean keep your your best foot
forward you know what I'm saying I
wouldn't be in the game if it wasn't for
myself I mean he he took a
he single-handedly took me under his
wing and you know shot shot a lot of
light on you know what I'm saying and I
learned like the business too you feel
me being on your being on your ball
standing on business
you know what I'm saying [ __ ] like that
it's real dope oh a lot to him uh
every chance I get you know I speak that
you know but you know what I'm saying
that's why you know being independent is
it's like it's kind of like easy for me
not easy because it's a lot of weight on
our shoulders and [ __ ] like that but you
know being independent you know we try
to like
you know tackle certain certain
mainstream tactics you know what I'm
saying right take certain mainstream
tactics and you know go with the flow
and [ __ ] like that you know because you
know being independent like you gotta
do do more of the the the work on the
business side more work yeah you know
what I'm saying for sure it's a lot more
work it's a lot more tedious but it's a
lot more rewarding the payoff is worth
it yeah for sure because this is your
second album since I guess leaving the
inner scope [ __ ] right
yes yeah actually
um
my first album was my first album period
on God was my first album period I would
when I was signed I was only signed for
uh two mixtapes which was two it was two
projects right which was Mr LA and the
ghetto right everything else was omnio
those were independent early those were
yeah those are independent release
records yeah you feel me so those arm
your records is what you know we have
titles that's amazing
um which keeps us afloat and keeps us
going I mean you got some [ __ ]
Classics man yeah some real classic a
little bit above a float but yes that's
fair